[Musica]
[Applauso]
adesso mi stupisco con una sorpresa
alzati in piedi per favore datemi le
spalle ora a gambe leggermente
divaricate belli solidi appoggiate il
palmo della vostra mano sulla schiena
del vostro vicino o della vostra vicina
di destra se non avete le immaginate ora
piegando vi tutti leggermente in avanti
ma abbastanza piegandoli leggermente in
avanti ma abbastanza da poter guardare a
testa in giù dietro di voi sotto il
nostro braccio piegato ok mi vedete
dovete cercare di vedermi
ecco il mondo a testa all'ingiù le gambe
degli uomini si agitano nell'aria il
calzoni scivolano giù e le ragazze le
ragazze come si danno da fare per tenere
ferme le gonne e la possiamo leggere
sull'insegna di un'osteria a nips alla
arriv dentro un cliente ha appena
ordinato la l'ordine è questo sopra la
birra sotto la schiuma
ma soprattutto c'è la base del bicchiere
oppure è inverno e coppie di pattinatori
scivolano ondeggiando sullo specchio
ghiacciato del cielo potete tornare in
posizione eretta
e girarvi da questa parte come vedete il
mondo si regge sui suoi piedi tutto
ritorna confortevole almeno per voi e
noi possiamo tirare un sospiro di
sollievo è stato solo un momento
sicuri sono stato invitato perché sono
il direttore di una federazione
nazionale ma sono anche un artista uno
spettatore è un cittadino come artista
ho sempre amato lo spazio pubblico
perché il luogo dell'imprevedibile per
quanto pronti al peggio
nello spazio pubblico di uno spettacolo
di strada può succedere di tutto perché
la vita stessa che lo attraversa se sei
un artista e la tua storia la vuoi
raccontare nello spazio pubblico
la prima cosa che impari intanto è che
prima ancora che la tua arte nutra la
strada sarà la strada ad aver nutrito
tempo ma impari anche soprattutto che
non puoi controllare l'imprevedibile
nemmeno con la pianificazione ma che ci
puoi giocare questo sì
e per farlo devi allenare la tua
fragilità e la tua debolezza perché
parla di debolezza perché cito stalker
di tarkovskij che a sua volta cita il
tao te ching e dice la debolezza e
potenza e la forza e niente quando un
uomo nasce è debole ed utile quando
muore è forte e rigido come la pianta
mentre cresce e tenera e flessibile e
quando è secca e dura muore per questo
per un artista il palco che è lo spazio
pubblico significa principalmente
imparare a farsi deboli flessibili
imparare ad accogliere e trasformare
imparare a danzare con questo
imprevedibile
e danzare con la vita
ma che cos'è lo spazio pubblico
queste sono le foto che chi ha
partecipato al gioco ha mandato nella
strada tra casa e pid dix sito un'altra
volta
james hillman psicanalista posto
junghiano che nel suo libro il codice
dell'anima dice la divisione in due
alternative è una comoda abitudine della
mente occidentale noi loro è la logica
aristotelica che organizza i suoi
sistemi per pro e contro aut aut
l'introduzione di qualcos'altro nel
mezzo viola la nostra modalità di
pensiero
noi loro centro periferia buoni cattivi
anche belli e brutti poveri e ricchi ma
anche centri ficazione e rigenerazione
urbana etica oppure europa non europa
ovunque attorno a noi
tendenzialmente veniamo ci viene chiesto
di prendere le parti di uno schieramento
o dell'altro spazio pubblico e spazio
privato nella società contemporanea
tendenzialmente vediamo che la società
individua come se il spazio pubblico
fosse altro da noi come fossi un luogo
fisico ben determinato che possiamo
raggiungere un quarto d'ora in macchina
io provo a ragionare in termini di
piuttosto di volume come se fosse un
volume attorno a noi un aura che ci
segue sempre ovunque e per farlo faccio
un esempio sono in bagno e sto facendo
la doccia
una folata di vento apre la finestra e
guarda caso in quel momento tutti ma
dico proprio tutti i miei vicini sono
sul palazzo di fronte
e mi guardano la mia azione da privata
diventa pubblica ma la stessa cosa posso
dire io della vicina che stendi panni di
cui lenzuola colorate mi rimandano a
tipo bandiere di un'estetica del sonno
domestico oppure gli odori della cucina
degli africani che abitano qui accanto
che mi rimanda a terra e dove ancora non
sono state nemmeno come turista o
vogliamo parlare dei vicini la coppia
qua sotto che litiga tutto il tempo e mi
chiedo perché non fanno come la coppia
qua sopra che passa il tempo ad ansimare
e genere storie
queste sono storie d'amore diversa tutte
storie che si raccontano quindi quel
volume lo possiamo considerare quasi uno
spazio di realtà aumentata che arriva
fino a dove arrivano i nostri sensi i
vostri sensi di spettatore per questo
come direttore come artista ma
soprattutto come spettatore sono sempre
stato affascinato l'esistenza di questo
spazio in mezzo dentro cui il rapporto
tra pubblico e privato si può ribaltare
in un istante
abbiamo visto il privato che diventa
pubblico bene vale anche il contrario io
scendo in piazza col mio spettacolo
ragazzi spacca e non c'è nessuno che mi
guarda
resta un atto privato per questo il
circo il teatro la danza la musica le
arti in genere quando scendono in strada
lo fanno perché vanno a cercarsi
qualcuno che li assista vanno a cercarsi
un pubblico noi nel network europeo di
cui facciamo parte che si chiama circo
strada
portiamo avanti una riflessione continua
anche attraverso degli eventi che si
chiamano frey street
una riflessione continua sul ruolo
dell'arte nello spazio e in rapporto
alle comunità che abitano questo spazio
e lo transitano il quarto capitolo di
questa saga si chiama the space in
between come professionisti ci poniamo
la domanda se oggi il territorio di
creazione dell'arte nello spazio
pubblico risiede esattamente in questo
spazio di mezzo ossia dentro la società
che è dilaniata tra identità culturali
monolitiche noi e loro ci interroghiamo
sul potenziale creativo di questo spazio
di transito che è tutto un pullulare di
materiale umano che merita di essere
raccolto trasformato e restituita in
forma d'arte questa riflessione non vale
soltanto per gli artisti e per spiegarmi
prendo di tutto il comparto delle arti
in strada la componente più anarchica
che è l'arte di strada ossia l'artista
che scende liberamente in strada a
cappello da noi non parliamo di mestiere
parliamo di libera espressione di
estemporaneità e di gratuita
questa cornice se da un lato toglie
l'artista la dignità del mestiere quando
scende in strada volontariamente
dall'altro lato ribaltando lo sguardo
come abbiamo fatto prima e attaccandoci
ha una tradizione culturale dei diritti
dell'uomo ben precisa ci permette di
vedere un'altra via ossia che l'arte di
strada tendenzialmente è affare di tutti
ci riguarda in quanto cittadini ossia
fosse anche solo una volta nella vita
ognuno di noi deve avere il diritto di
poter scendere in strada a esprimersi
artisticamente rivolto lo sguardo come
nel gioco ritorno dritto e il mondo al
contrario cosa vedo che il diritto è
anche una responsabilità ossia nessuno
di noi si può esimere
dal vivere artisticamente lo spazio
pubblico perché siamo giocatori siamo
player di un gioco collettivo e tutte le
nostre scelte sia di azione che di
inazione cambiano lo scenario è il
livello di gioco anche per tutti quanti
gli altri
per questo la riflessione sullo spazio
di mezzo riguarda l'urbanistica
l'architettura ingegneri civile riguarda
la politica riguarda anche le tecnologie
per le città
l'attivismo riguarda la cittadinanza
attiva
riguarda tutto quindi l'invito che io mi
sento di condividere con voi oggi è
quale che sia il vostro mestiere o quale
che sia la vostra vocazione come la
chiama il man fiate perché lo siete
artisti e siate creatori perché lo siete
ma questo spazio di indagine fino a che
punto si spinge la logica aristotelica
ci dice vesti una casacca identitaria o
noi o loro
ecco con un caro amico antropologo il
professore paolo apolito avuto la
pazienza di sopportarsi in alcune
imprese in questi anni abbiamo imparato
che identità idem identico è un concetto
che antropologicamente è un fake
non esiste niente uguale a se stesso
esiste un'identità che paolo chiama jazz
e la sviluppa come un intreccio in
continuo divenire mai uguale a se stesso
il territorio in cui avviene questo
intreccio è lo spazio pubblico e l'arte
è la disciplina che attiva l'intreccio
ma la cosa interessante è dove stanno i
fili della trama di questo intreccio i
figli stanno nello spazio delle
relazioni stanno tra me e voi stanno tra
voi due
e voi due tra voi e loro stanno tra di
noi
e tutti quelli fuori ma se lo spazio
pubblico diventa lo spazio della
relazione delle relazioni
qual è adesso qui il vostro spazio
pubblico e potete dire in quanto
cittadini artisti che questo spazio
qui e ora non vi riguarda e che non
spetti anche a voi e non solo a noi di
lasciare un segno in dono agli altri tre
stasera quando torneranno a casa
rispondo io no quindi alzati in piedi
per favore e guardate bene intorno a voi
questo spazio tra di voi giratevi
respirata affonda e fatevi deboli fatevi
duttili fateli flessibili
perché adesso rischiamo tutti avete 30
secondi di tempo per pensare non fare
pensare a un'azione estemporanea di
libera espressione artistica da donare
ai vostri vicini o ai vostri lontani
pensatela si muove può essere la voce no
vi ricordo giusto una strofa della
poesia delle medie la dico oppure un
canto il ritornello della canzone di
tiziano ferro me la cavo così oppure
sono fisicamente in sono bloccatissimo e
potrei essere la perfetta statua vivente
ora ribaltiamo il mondo al contrario
stanno in piedi
voi siete gli artisti e io uno
spettatore
siete pronti player hicks
cominciamo si comincia
sì solo lei nessun altro grazie mille